i live off the yield and the dividends i
never touch
the investment i know exactly what i'm
going to bring in and i have the
discipline not to spend more than i'm
bringing in every month that's
it's it's a very simple philosophy in
life the more you make the more of a
lavish lifestyle you can have but you
never touch the principle and if you can
pay down your debts because you've got
to be debt free by the time you're 60
years old
[Music]
most of us if you're anything like me
you've spent your entire career earning
money
and never learning how to create wealth
number one write this down three things
and then i'm gonna invite my friend
kevin o'leary in to talk to us to give
us his angle
on the fastest way to get to a million
dollars number one
three things you got to know about money
okay we'll dig in deep this week number
one you got to earn it you got to get it
how do i get it how do i get some
uh redneck in me just like get some
number two how do i keep it once i get
it number three most people never learn
this one jay-z learned it he learned how
to get it he learned how to keep it he
learned how to elevate it and then he
learned how to multiply
and that's why he killed a billion
you're not gonna kill a billion dollars
or a hundred million earning money
you're gonna do it because you learned
how to create wealth and get money to
multiply the third thing is the thing
that all of us here
all of us that want to create wealth for
ourselves for whatever reason for your
family for yourself for your reputation
for your ego for the boat
whatever it is to create real wealth you
need to learn how to multiply let's get
mr kevin o'leary here this guy is a
super stud you've seen him on cnbc you
see him on abc you see him on
goddamn where is he not
he's everywhere
one of the best they're actually just
they just finished shooting they
finished the shooting jared's telling me
one of the he's definitely the best
looking shark of all the sharks he is
the smartest shark of all the sharks he
is the best investor of all the sharks
and he is my friend kevin o'leary good
to see you here my friend
great to be here grant really great so
kevin thanks for taking your time i
appreciate it always good you know i
always enjoyed chopping it up with you
um
what do you say kevin is the difference
between the earner and the investor
there's a few rules that um i've
observed over 30 years of investing
where people make big mistakes and also
are very successful because they avoid
them
the the earner
learns how to take a portion of what
they earn and invest it and i'll tell
you a story that i like to tell that i
learned from my mother
now way back she was not you know a
analyst or portfolio manager or anything
like that she used to take 20 percent of
her income when she worked in a clothing
factory
and she bought telco bonds
and she bought s p 500 stocks that paid
dividends
and she had that portfolio for 52 years
back in those days the bonds earned six
to seven percent
she liked telco bonds because she
thought people turned their heat off
rather than not be able to talk to each
other back in those days in the late 50s
and 60s with telephones you had to pay
your bill
and telco bonds were safe as banks and
that's what happened so over that 52
years she kept that a secret account
from both of her husbands she'd be
married twice
and i learned about all this after she
passed away i'm the older brother and my
younger brother uh shane i got a call
from the executor
at the you know the of the state and uh
was passing that to me a lawyer and said
you got to come down here your mother
died a very wealthy woman i said no way
we're middle class family he said way
get down here and see this portfolio 52
years of compound
dividends and interest she only ever
took out
what the interest or the dividend was
she never touched the principal
she died and i always wondered where she
has cash to put me through college and
help extended family members
it wasn't that she was frugal it was
just she took that 20 percent earnings
and she didn't buy crap she invested it
and that that was the difference and so
many people today
don't have that basic instinct to take
some portion of what they earn and
invest it because the market gives you
seven to eight percent year in year out
their years some years are different but
it consistently does that your entire
life
god works you got to tell me what it was
worth you can't keep me hanging like
this man
no she die i won't say that because i've
told the story so many times but it was
one
poop load of money
and you know what i did with it because
i'd already i was very fortunate at that
time i i'd already had some great
liquidity so i distributed it to
you know some of my family members that
that had not learned the rule of of
saving and investing so kevin would you
rather be
just for this conversation you and i
didn't plan any of this we're just
talking here so would you rather be a
big earner or small investor
small investor all day long i have this
thing called know your nut grant listen
to this and i do this with really
wealthy people too know your nut
you don't need a computer you don't need
a phone you don't need anything you need
a piece of paper and a pencil listen to
this i ask them
just show me all of your income over a
90 day period
and on another sheet of paper what you
spend in that 90 day period i don't want
computers i just want you to think about
how you make it and even really wealthy
people spend beyond their means
it's incredible the boats the cars the
girls the restaurants all the stuff that
they're burning cash on that they're not
putting back into the market
and the whole idea is that you got to
start thinking about what happens when
you turn 60 and 65 you got to start
putting money away and build that nut
that nest egg if you don't know you're
nut
you're going to go bankrupt that's
what's going to happen or you're going
to end up with nothing when you're old
because you're burning more cash than
you got
yeah and kevin would you rather earned
income or passive income
passive income
she's because i i hear some people say i
heard one guy say a big social media
guys no such thing as passive income i'm
like i got a million dollars at that
last month
like if it's not real i don't know how
it got to my account because i didn't
trade time for it
and well i think the the philosophical
way to look at this is
is
when you have money
working for you all night long you're
sleeping and it's out there doing its
thing either giving you interest or a
dividend or it's in a capital that is
growing because you're you're invested
in a business
that was money you had two choices you
could have spent it on something like
you know cars or something
and just pissed it away or you put it to
work in the market which is making you
seven eight percent in perpetuity and
sometimes more and so it's really about
having the discipline to put money aside
i'm very fortunate now i've invested in
a lot of good businesses
and
most of my wealth is because i invested
in things that that became more valuable
and sometimes very short periods of time
and
i don't need to work i do it because i
like to but i don't waste money i know
my nut i know exactly
what i burn and i never burn more than
i'm bringing home
never
and then so when you buy the red watch
what are you wearing today oh thank you
for bringing that up this is uh a steel
blackface daytona with a red band i just
got back from shooting shark tank it's
one of my favorite shark tank watches
okay
by the way this watch is up grant just
so you know since i bought it 114
i know that yeah but but it's not up
because you're not going to sell it so
what does it matter no i know but i mean
my portfolio of watches is an asset
class to me it's like buying art and i
mark to mark my my portfolio of watches
i'm anal about it every night i look at
what my watch collection's worth now my
wife thinks i'm nuts when i bring home
another watch and i show her my
portfolio it's not going to be for me my
son thinks he's going to get these but
i've told everybody in my family i'm
burying all these watches in my casket
with me because i'm going to need them
where i'm going
we're no time where time does not exist
so so now if you're 25 years old let's
take kevin o'leary 25 you're not on
you're not on shark tank nobody knows
you you don't have a name
would you have your attention today you
wouldn't be buying rolexes right
no no i this so this is a luxury that i
can afford today
and it's a disease a watch collecting is
a disease i'm i mean i'm afflicted
yesterday 1 000
what what kind of principles would you
have first of all do you believe it's
real if you were 25 and broke
whether you live in canada or america
that that you could become a millionaire
in america today
yeah i did that that's exactly what i
did i didn't become a millionaire in
canada i moved to boston years ago and i
worked real hard but you know i i had
that discipline back then
i didn't want to be an employee i don't
know how to do that i don't know how to
work for people never could always got
fired
um i just can't do it and so i started
my own business and i work like hell
and we sold it for 4.2 billion that was
years ago years ago in boston and that
was my first uh you know crack at the
whip and if you want to call it that and
then i retired for three years went
around the world everywhere i got back
to work and you know i've been very
fortunate since then i've had many
winners and many losers but the point is
you got to believe in yourself and
you've got to focus on investing you've
got you've got to put capital to work
and let it grow yeah but you're not
making any money putting in the bank
yeah in the beginning though
like how important is it for the
individual to make a commitment and not
just to a job doing a good job getting
better at their job but like okay i'm
going to create wealth for myself is
that an important step to make
it's the most important step and the way
you do that is you have the discipline
to put aside between ten and twenty
percent of what i don't care if you make
fifty grand if you make fifty two
thousand five hundred is the average
income in america you take ten percent
of that
each month and you invest in the market
the stock market an index i don't care
what you buy and by the time you're 65
years old you will have about a million
and a half dollars in the bank and
that's your nest egg that's if you do
nothing else except save 10 percent you
have to have the discipline of doing
that
but i tell everybody that all the time
now you may do much better but if you
just let the market do its thing and you
have the discipline not to spend that
money everybody can save ten percent of
what they're making everybody can
everybody they just don't have the
discipline to do it and if you don't do
that i don't care if you're 40 years old
you got to start doing that the market's
a wonderful thing grant it's a wonderful
thing i live with it every day i put
money to work what do you like better
the real real estate that i invest in or
the stock market did you that you talk
about every day
i do both i have a pretty big real
estate
how big how big is it
well it's 31 of the portfolio right now
it's a little less because i've invested
in a bunch of other stuff too but it's
always the core i own a lot of real
estate now real estate is a wonderful
thing
but you know it can cost you money if
it's just land it could cost you money
if it's residential and you're not
renting it out but it's an asset class
that has never let america down ever so
you want to own some land you want to
own some buildings you want to own some
apartments you can do all that and you
do that well but i'm i'm that that's a
30 that's a third that's a good nut
that's i do a lot of other things too
but real estate
you know you're a sophisticated guy
you're a sophisticated guy i'm just a
simple man
no but listen
you're the one you know how you know
when somebody's sophisticated when they
know how to read the french wines we
were having dinner over at uh circling
surf club and and i said kevin i can't
read this wine list can can can you and
he's like oh i mean how do you say it
how do you do all your french and stuff
now the chevellier de testa that's what
i am and i i know wines i sell wines
i've got a pretty big wine business i've
got 3 000 acres in california and sonoma
and walla walla valley that i own or
lease i make wine i mean that's my whole
thing but you know i'll tell you
something grant the whole idea is
putting aside money for yourself that's
the key that's the key it's so important
it's it's like everything yeah you know
if you study if you go back to the 1920s
when the big uh the big collapsed uh
what was that called the great
depression if you look at the what the
wealthy were doing at that time as much
as 40 of their their income was going to
investing and saving are you already
drinking today
dang man no that's a little t you got
the life um so so that i saw that i went
and studied wealthy people back for for
that the last 80 years and i'm like
these people are packing away 20 in bad
times 40
but they weren't just saving and
debating they were doing what your mom
was doing buying things that paid
uh a dividend how do people invest today
when all these dividend stocks are gone
at t pays nothing general motors pays
nothing the banks paid
zero one two .0012
what what would you be invested in uh
for those that want income on a monthly
basis
so
i use the etf market exchange traded
funds actually that's i don't buy
individual stocks i find etfs there's
many of them out there
right now the s p 500 is paying about
1.8 percent dividend yield but it's also
appreciating in value 78 a year
sometimes the last couple of years much
better than that
so you know i i there's so many of them
they're inexpensive and you can you can
download an app on your phone to do it
there's so many of those
here's the difference right now a bank
account a savings account is yielding 21
basis points that's point two one
percent inflation is two point two
percent you're making nothing you're
losing two percent a year in a bank now
people think oh that's safe i can put my
money in the bank but i don't think it's
that safe because it's losing two
percent a year in value either you buy
real estate or you buy stocks you have
to buy assets you got to decide what
you're going to do i prefer assets
because i learn from my mother that
produce some kind of interest or
dividend
i live off the yield and the dividends i
never touch
the investment
i don't sell it i've owned these things
for decades and then each month i know
my nut i know exactly what i'm going to
bring in and i have the discipline not
to spend more than i'm bringing in every
month that's it's it's a very simple
philosophy on life the more you make the
more of a lavish lifestyle you can have
but you never touch the principle and if
you can
pay down your debts because you've got
to be debt-free by the time you're 60
years old so you're saying you live off
the dividend or the passive income not
the earned income am i right you don't
you don't it's the passive income i take
that earned income after tax and i
invest it right so i invested it and
that's how i grow my nut that's how i
grow my nuts so your earned income
is the money you invest
and the passive income is the money you
can buy the rolex with
exactly exactly and i know my nut every
month i mark to market what i own i see
the cash coming in on the past
investments so all of this stuff we got
a bunch of houses i love real estate i
got to pay for all those too and
maintain them but i know my nut i never
spend more than i'm bringing in it's i
learned that from my mother
when i was 18 years old
and
i've never ever ever ever
ever got over what i make bringing in
that's a really bad outcome really bad
uh last thing before we go to our vips
and we do a little q a and let those
guys ask you questions um
what advice would you have the person
out there with out there that that's out
there that's like man i could never be a
millionaire
i'll never be wealthy i'll never get
rich those times are over the
opportunities are over they're gone what
advice would you give that person
that's simply not true that's simply not
true it's just not true that you
don't die a millionaire
you have to have the dis every person
listening right now can be a millionaire
i say a million five if they just took
10 percent of what they make on an
average salary and put it away you start
when you're 22 years old it's it's r
the hardest part and i teach my kids is
too the hardest part is
don't buy crap you don't need 15 pairs
of jeans you don't need 40 sneakers you
don't need a lot of crap you bought that
should be in the market making money for
you that's the whole idea and that's the
hardest part but everybody can die a
millionaire if they learn to put aside
10 percent in the market not a savings
account that's not going to do it for
you 21 basis one ain't going to work
either you buy real estate or you buy
stocks and bonds they've both been good
investments for 200 years and how much
last thing is how much do you think is
enough like what should people's real
target be to be
truly wealthy financially free do you
think there's a number
that gets you there
it's your lifestyle decision you can
live off a million and a half dollars if
you're frugal you can do it there's a
way you absolutely you can do that if
you want to have a more lavish lifestyle
you work harder you save more in your
early years
most people live within their means
it depends how lavish you want to be
i love the nut the number i like that i
strove for for so long when i was young
i told my dad this and my mother if only
i could figure out a way
to put five million dollars aside
and i worked like hell to get that first
five the rest was real easy after that i
mean i don't i mean because once once
you have money you can make money that's
the whole point yeah how critical do you
think having that target locked in on
like even though it was a fantasy to you
you didn't know how to get there you
didn't know the mechanics but you locked
in on that five million how important
was that you gotta have that locked in
number because it for you know what
happens is you're thinking about buying
something and you got your nut you got
your number you say to yourself do i
really need this piece of crap and the
answer is no i'm going to put it towards
my target
i mean you're teaching the right
disciplines here i don't care if your
target's a million bucks i don't care if
it's 500 000 you gotta hit your target
and the way you do it is you have the
discipline not to spend money on crap
you don't need yeah so locking on the
target so the belt doesn't look as the
belt the trip the car you don't need
that stuff once you hit your target you
set a new one you say i want more i mean
look that's the american way if you like
that video wait did you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe